Star Trek Picard is coming gone and the
biggest surprise of the Season might be
that the crew of the Enterprise D got a
happy ending but could there be more
adventures in their future if every Star
Trek fan had sat down and watched the
Star Trek Picard season 3 finale at the
same time their Collective size of
relief at the end of the episode would
have been deafening despite numerous
close calls and fake outs the returning
cast of Star Trek the Next Generation
all made it out of the season-long Caper
alive the uplifting ending enjoyed by
these characters has certainly been
welcomed by fans but some may be
wondering how none of the original Next
Generation crew bit the dust throughout
the story in an interview with inverse
Picard's showrunner Terry matalis spoke
about the creative team's decision to
keep all the classic crew members alive
he said honestly it would be very easy
to kill off one of these characters and
it would be entirely appropriate but I
didn't have an inmate to do it in a
weird way I wanted the surprise ending
to be that it was a happy ending a
desire for a happy ending might have
been the main reason that the writers
ended up keeping every Next Generation
crew member alive but there may also be
another reason for the decision the
Picard from alley is meant to be a final
farewell to several major characters
including the titular Captain himself
however there is a slight chance a
metallis might return to a few of the
characters in future project in the
finale's shocking post-credits scene
Jack Crusher encounters Q who he
believed to be dead
young mortal you have much ahead of you
Hugh cryptically suggests that Jack is
due for a trial leaving a dangling plot
thread that would be right for a
Picard's spin-off to tackle metallist
tells inverse I know how this would all
go if we were lucky enough to come back
if mattalus ends up developing another
series it's quite possible that the
platy envisions could involve characters
from The Next Generation the same is
true for the broader sphere of Star Trek
projects by keeping the classic crew
alive there is always the potential that
they could be brought back for another
adventure if this situation calls for it
in essence Picard gave its characters a
happy ending with just enough narrative
wiggle room to bring them back it seems
that many veteran cast members of Star
Trek the Next Generation aren't ready to
say goodbye to their characters just yet
either during the release of Picard's
third season Patrick Stewart was candid
about returning to the franchise once
more he told reporters there is still
enormous potential for matters and what
we can do and there are doors left open
and we didn't close all of them several
months later Stewart expressed interest
to Variety in returning for a Star Trek
Legacy spin-off along with Ed speelers
he noted if I can occasionally crop up
to offer a little bit of Comedy myself
and I shall be happy to do that several
of Stewart's fellow Next Generation
actors have voiced similar wishes
Jonathan Prague seems keen on returning
as Riker as he tweeted a vague message
indicating that Star Trek Picard might
not be his final go around with the
franchise meanwhile LeVar Burton and
Brent Spiner said in a joint interview
with variety that's while they have some
reservations about returning beyond the
card they aren't shutting the door
completely spider said Levar and I've
talked about the fact that if this lands
in a way that we hope it lands maybe it
would be best to be the finale and if
there should be something more than this
well as he said that would just be
another gift that we can't really
contemplate at the moment